Go ahead. What's your What's your
question?
>> I apologize. Uh, my background is Roman
Catholic. I've been watching your stream
for about a year and a half now. Uh, I
was reading through the Bible and I
passed through Colossians 3:8 and I was
confused, but I know that you have a
biblical interpretation of the the Well,
I don't know. I assume you have a
biblical interpretation of the Bible. I
trust you.
>> Um, and I I want to harmonize that with
what I know from you.
>> I don't don't trust me too much because
I don't trust myself. So, what's your
problem with Colossians 3:8? uh
basically the context that it talks
about filthy language in and not
speaking in filthy language and I just
basically want to harmonize it with what
you've taught me.
>> So why do you want me to harmonize it?
>> Uh I don't understand it. I don't
understand how to harmonize it with the
other things that you've taught about
how uh basically the Bible tells about
good men cursing out bad some extent.
>> Both statements are in the Bible. So
then either you have a Bible full of
contradictions or Okay. So you tell me
how how would that be apply? Especially
what about Colossians 4:6. That one's
even more difficult. Read Colossians
4:6, mister.
>> Colossians 4:6. Give me a moment. Let me
type that in.
46.
Uh, let your conversation be always full
of grace, seasoned with salt, so that
you may know how to answer everyone.
Wait.
>> Wow. How do we reconcile that with all
those other statements, mister?
>> Uh, well, that's why I'm learning.
That's why I'm still a baby.
>> You think about it, man. Okay. So, you
think about it, dude. If all those
statements are in the Bible,
>> well, I imagine the the cursing out of
dogs is something that is something
that's different from just speaking on
normal terms with other Christians and
with those who you might consider
family, those who you might consider
close rather than
>> only family. But aren't can't you have
family members that oppose you on your
enemies and blaspheme?
>> That's true. Maybe it's for the purpose
of protecting those who don't
understand. And if it's in the context
of maybe a heated debate rather than in
a conversation between you and another
person. I'm not.
>> So again, when do you think
a passage is applicable? If you have
both statements in scripture, let your
conversation be seasoned with salt,
right? And do not insult curse one
another. And yet you have the same
apostles, God Christ insulting, cursing
people. Even have improvatory psalms
where psalm is
The psalmists are praying God's wrath
and destruction on people. Help me
understand. Come on.
>> I I won't lie, Sam. I'm I'm very lost on
this. That's That's why I came to you.
>> Why you be lost, man?
>> Think you're giving up too easy? Come
on, man.
>> I
Oh,
>> your confusion because you haven't
listened enough to the sessions. I've
addressed this. Read for me Proverbs 26.
Open up Proverbs 26. Proverbs
26.
>> Yeah, just open up the entire chapter.
>> Okay,
>> read verse four for me.
>> Verse four. Do not answer a fool
according to his folly, or you yourself
will be just like him.
>> So, should I stoop to the level of fool
and act like him?
>> No. You Well, it says that you will be
just like him if you do.
>> But you don't do that, right?
>> Yeah.
>> But read verse five. Answer a fool
according to his folly, or he will be
wise in his own eyes.
>> You just confused me. You just gave me
two contradictory statements side by
side.
>> Read verse four again.
>> Do not answer a fool according to his
folly, or you yourself will be just like
him.
>> Now read verse five.
>> Answer a fool according to his folly, or
he will be wise in his own eyes.
>> But wait, verse four says, don't answer
a fool according to his folly. Verse
five says, answer a fool according to
his folly.
I am I am so lost
>> because you're thinking, okay, well, it
says be gracious. All right, all the
time. So when Jesus insulted people,
rebuked people, overturned tables and
took a whip of cords and drove people
out. So now Jesus is being a hypocrite.
>> No, Jesus is not being a hypocrite.
>> So when Paul calls people sons of the
devil, enemies of all righteous, calls
them dogs, is Paul being a hypocrite?
>> No. Absolutely. Where's the confusion?
If you understand
that
a passage will be applicable depending
on the situation that you're in.
>> Okay.
>> Where's the confusion? That's
Ecclesiastes 18.
>> There is no confusion. Then um
>> Ecclesiastes 3 verse8, mister.
Ecclesiastes
is
>> 318. Chapter 3 verse8
>> 128.
>> Okay. Uh, do you want me to read out the
full passage?
>> Please read out loud, mister.
>> There's a time for everything and a
season for every activity under the
heavens. A time to be born and a
>> There's a time for what?
>> Uh, a season for every activity under
the earth.
>> Before that, a time for what?
>> There's a time for everything.
>> Oh, so there's a time to insult people
and be kind to people.
>> Yes.
And a season for everything.
>> A season to insult people and be
gracious to people.
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> Where's the contradiction?
>> There is no contradiction.
>> Now read the verses follow. It tells you
>> a time to be born and a time to die. A
time to plant and a time to uproot. A
time to kill and a time to heal.
>> Oh, wait. Healing and killing. There's
always a time for one or the other.
>> Correct.
>> But how can you reconcile that? That's a
contradiction. You either heal or you
kill.
Right. So it's it it is situational. It
is circumstantial then too.
>> Thank you. Where's the problem, brother?
Shoot.
>> Then then there's there's no problem. I
suppose then what I I'd want to ask is
well right. You told me let the spirit
guide me for those situations.
>> How am I going to know? Because it
depends on the circumstancer you're
dealing with.
>> Right. That's true.
>> All right. But finish it. There's not
all there's more.
>> Okay. A time to tear down and a time to
build. A time to
>> Hold on. When it's time to tear down,
should you be building?
>> No.
>> So, when it's time to build, should you
be tearing down?
>> No.
>> So, when it's time to be gracious,
should you be insulting?
>> No.
>> When it's time to insult someone because
they're blasphemy, should you be
gracious?
>> No.
>> There you go, brother. Keep reading.
>> A time to weep and a time to laugh. A
time to mourn and a time to dance.
>> So, at a funeral, should you be
laughing?
>> No.
At a comedy show, should you be crying?
>> Probably not.
>> Unless he's boring as hell.
>> He's really boring.
>> All right. So, at a wedding service,
should you be crying and mourning and
wearing black?
>> Yes.
>> At a wedding, huh?
>> Oh, sorry. No, no, not at a wedding
service.
>> That tells us how you want people to
feel at your wedding.
So when people come to a wedding and
they're wearing black and they're
mourning and wailing Calaldian style,
is that appropriate time?
>> No, it's not an appropriate time.
>> Why not?
>> Um I suppose that would be that would be
rather rude to the bride and to the
groom.
>> But wait, brother, it says there's a
time to weep. Didn't it say that right
there?
>> It it did say that. Yeah. So why can't I
weep and mourn at that time when they're
married and we're all wearing black, all
the Calaldanss come in, they don't go
because that's what they do in the
wedding. They go
[Music]
why can't they do it then?
>> Um it would be inappropriate, I suppose.
>> Oh, because that's a time to laugh,
>> right? That's the time to laugh. That's
the time
>> rejoice, right?
>> Yep. What if
at a funeral service they start dancing
on
and they bring you know doa where they
bring the drums and the horn.
>> Uh that would be that would be rather
inappropriate I imagine.
>> Why? It says there's a time to laugh. So
why not laugh at a funeral?
Uh, it would be extremely disrespectful
to everyone involved who actually cares.
Well,
>> so wait, wait. You're telling me when a
woman is burying the body of her husband
and she's in black and morning. It's not
the time to say, "Come on, lady. You
free now. Let's get out of Come on."
You sure?
>> I'm Yeah, I'm pretty sure.
>> Positive?
>> Yeah, I'm positive.
>> All right, keep reading.
Uh,
a time to scatter stones and a time to
gather them. A time to embrace and a
time to refrain from embracing. All
right. So, when your wife is very
emotional and broken. It says there's a
time to embrace and a time to what?
>> And a time to refrain from embracing.
>> So, your wife is broken and she's crying
and you refuse to embrace her. And she
goes, "Why?" Because it says there's a
time to refrain from embracing. This is
the time
>> that
>> you know you're not going to be married
for long, right?
>> Yeah. She will be divorcing.
>> You sure?
>> Uh well that are killing.
>> Yeah. But you say hold on. It says
there's a time to refrain from
embracing. I'm just being biblical here.
>> Right.
>> So this is what happens. This is what
happens when someone call quotes to me
Colossians 4:6. Let your conversation be
seasoned. Right.
>> Right.
Okay, I get that. Yeah. Who says that
every conversation you insult and cuss
someone out every time?
But then what about those places where
Jesus insults, curses people, calls them
adulterers, calls them vipers. I guess
they don't know the Bible after all. Now
finish it. Keep going.
>> A time to search and a time to give up.
A time to keep and a time to throw away.
A time to tear and a time to mend. A
time to be silent and a time to speak.
>> All right. So when it's time for you to
speak up in defense of the faith and you
go silent. Someone says why? Because it
says a time to be silent.
Are you applying that passage correctly?
>> No. No. That would definitely be
inappropriate.
>> But now notice another thing. It says a
time to give up.
That principle is applicable to every
aspect of the Christian life. There's a
time where you have to give up and walk
away. Even if it's from a relationship
that you see, it's not going anywhere
because the other person is resistant
and you not cannot force them to do what
is right.
>> Right?
>> So when you have a child that is
addicted to drugs and doesn't want to
give up and you keep chasing them and
you keep doing everything you can, then
now you're enabling them. You're not
helping them. There's a time where you
have to give up, cut off ties, hand them
over to the Lord.
>> Right?
>> And that is also true with marriage. If
one of your if a spouse checks out and
she leaves you or he leaves you and
doesn't want to return, you don't keep
chasing them like a dog. You need to
give up. Hand them to the Lord and let
God deal with them.
>> Yeah. Lord knows that's true. That is
>> So there is no contradiction. Now finish
it all the way to
A time to be silent and a time to speak.
A time to love and a time to hate.
>> What? So you mean there is a time to
hate?
>> Yes, that is.
>> No,
>> that is what it reads.
>> No, man. I thought God is love. You
can't hate.
>> Do you want me to show you all the
verses where it says God hates the
sinner and the sin, too?
>> I've I've seen many of your sessions on
it.
>> All right.
>> There is no contradiction, brother.
There's a time to love and there's a
time to hate.
>> Okay. But now when you finish eight, let
me know. Keep going. Eight.
>> A time for war and a time for peace.
>> Why do you think people are having a
hard time with what Israel Netanyahu is
doing in Gaza? Because it's not a time
for war.
>> It is not a time for war. No. Yeah. And
it's uh it's really disturbing what's
what's been going on there, too.
>> Because he's a son of Satan. And he
justifies it because he calls them
Amalachites. He goes Amalch. That's the
language he uses. butchering first 1st
Samuel 15 and applying it to them saying
they're the Amalachites.
>> It's really disgusting to be honest.
>> Okay.
>> Now, am I being righteous in my hatred
of him?
>> Yes. Yes, you are.
>> Oh, but wait. I thought you're supposed
to love your enemy. You're not girth.
Because this is what happens when you
put the Bible in the hands of someone
untrained,
>> right?
>> And if you want to remember this
passage, they they made it a song. Did
you know Ecclesiastes 3:18, there's a
song? I did not know that.
>> Anyway, did that answer your question?
>> Yeah, that answered my question. Thank
you.
>> Anything else? Are you okay? You're
happy now?
>> Um,
I'm happy now. Yeah.
>> You sure? Are you sure it's time for you
to be happy and not to cry?
>> Uh, well,
I I think so. I think it's a time for me
to be happy. I got my question answered
and I'm
>> Anything else? Any other question or
you're good?
>> Uh, I'm good.
>> All right. Good. Make sure it's not a
time for me to make you cry.
>> Okay, brother. Bless you. God bless you.
This is God bless you.